hello and welcome to what's new in
enterprise maps my name is Dylan Thomas
I'm on the Google Enterprise Maps team
and joining me today is I J Hamm nanny
thanks Dylan thanks for having me no
problem so what we're going to talk
about today is a what the team has
released over the past 90 days and the
highlights thereof so as a customer you
may know that you get to a preview of
what we're going to be working on in the
product roadmap and we like to do a bit
of a retrospective and see what's cool
that we released in the past 90 days
we're going to look at three products
we're going to look at five features on
the maps engine side we're going to look
at how to get data into Maps engine via
the API some improvements in the styling
and the presentation and data and
finally some image referencing now we're
going to switch gears look at the places
API where we've got some improvements in
auto complete and we're going to wrap it
up with a brand new app so a jade you
want to start off with the maps engine
data import sure Dylan so first things
first the maps engine API has been able
to do a few things allow us to look at
data yeah ask questions again data yeah
and now the API has been extended to
allow us to be able to get data into our
Maps engine account so we used to be
able to do it well we could feature by
feature I like add a feature exactly
feature but you're talking about bulk
upload right exactly getting tables in
getting raster image REE in even
creating an empty table and so I'm
specifically going to talk about two
features right here the first one gives
us the ability to upload new data
sources through the API this could work
for vector as well as wrestlers haha the
second allows us to create a new empty
vector table so that you know after
after which you'll be able to use the
batch insert or batch update to
periodically insert records into the
table so the missing the missing piece
as far as our partners and customers
were concerned whether was was the
initial creations that create that empty
thing right to start doing the inserts
exactly right yeah
and I have a demo prepared for each of
these I'm going to jump into it right
away I'm going to be using the OAuth
playground for running these demos so
that I can share what the request looks
like it or the response object look I'd
like but to get things started first you
need to specify the scope and so I'm
going to use the READ&WRITE scope right
here authorize the API and get the OAuth
token running right so once that's done
I've got something prepared over here
I'm going to start with the create new
empty table example and so take a look
at the endpoint request so that's triple
w google api commes les maps and gin /
31 / tables I'm gonna director only
right right exactly that and that's a
post request so I'm going to change this
to post and in the request body right
here I've prepared this so one of the
things that you'll see in the request
body is the project ID and this you can
easily get by running one of the other
API request again so you can get this
from the UI as well as exactly like to
write yeah and the other things that
typical things that you would have
entered even if you had created or
uploaded a table directly over at the
console table name description and so on
and so forth so all that good starts
right here over the last few lines is
basically the schema of the table
imagine creating a table inside the
database should specify the column so
exactly the attributes you ok right so
I'm going to go ahead and close this and
run this query or right and over the
results side of things you will see the
schema that i created the table width
along with the asset ID that's that gets
created and assigned to this new asset
which is a vector table and i'm going to
go into the maps engine console and
display the data sources so for partners
and customers who are building
integrations between their systems and
maps engine this really just is that
there was the missing piece that exactly
that filled the gap right right
and here i believe is the table that we
just created there we go this is the
schema and details about metadata about
the table one more thing I wanted to
bring to everyone's attention is the
fact that with this request I had
created the table using the same name as
I had tried last night right so i end up
with two or more tables with the same
name which is not a problem because they
all have different asset IDs but come
the time when you need to search through
your inventory that could be different
or some exactly so that's one watch mine
you want to take into it so we had a bit
of a laugh about this earlier we call it
the RJ rule which is yeah don't worry
don't names things the same yes so the
second thing you're going to look at was
a vector and raster oriented which is
bulk upload of data right exactly that
and so I have something prepared right
here so the main request changes a
little again I'm going to be using oil
playground to send the request so still
starting with the same dorm a triple w
google api scom / maps engine / v 1 /
table / upload all right and so the
request body also changes a little
you'll still have the usual suspects
like the table name table description
and so on and so forth but apart from
that since here this request is talking
about uploading a data source I need to
be more specific with what makes up this
data source yeah right and so here is a
list of the files that make up this
particular vector data source and again
just to reiterate you're using a
shapefile vector-based but of course you
can upload images here to exactly that
right this is just examples showing a
vector but you can do that with with
imagery as well the other thing about
the upload functionality is that it
happens in two steps yeah in this first
step I'm just describing what the data
source looks like it's made up of four
files and in the second step i'll be
uploading the files one by one so it's
really exactly it's exactly like using
the you i mean the same steps as in the
UI right just exactly metadata upload
the data same thing right
go ahead and send the request and again
like expect it you will see some of the
details that you get included in the
metadata during the request and so
here's a list of all the files that are
going to be making part of the upload
one other thing that you need to take a
good look at is right here is the asset
ID that gets created because in your
upload step you specify which asset ID
am I uploading this file for so in your
script or code that's the that's the
single piece of information exactly that
and I'm just going to quickly bring up
the doc and show you the request where
the request looks like there go and
right here is where you're expected to
enter it right right okay I wish you
just add that the maps developer
relations team did a great videos is
Josh Livni and mark MacDonald did one in
mid-december so if you look for
importing data into Google Maps engine
if you look for that you'll see a video
that has a point is to some great code
samples using the Python or wealth
library or excuse me the client library
from google so if you want more about
this in particular this is a this is the
place to look for details thanks so
should we uh switch gears now and look
at the I think the second item we wanted
to I was some styling there's been great
improvement in the styling aspect
especially for vector styles and so this
basically goes into you know creating
richer cartography beautiful maps more
informative and so I have a short demo
right here to share let me pull that up
I'm going to use an existing data source
that I upload it again last night here's
a data source that has polylines
describing the various rivers and lakes
I believe and so what I'm going to do is
create a star player just give it a new
name
and as I create the first display rule
give it a name over here what you'll
notice are two main improvements first
is the ability to choose various kinds
of symbologies for displaying the lines
on top of the base map tiles so let me
stick with this and maybe I change the
color and do something more visible
right here and the other cool thing is
the ability to display one of the
attribute values as a label on top of
the geometric in this case which is a
polyline so I'm going to choose the name
attribute and the color stays is black
I'm going to choose a very obvious
outline so it so it's the rule just
because you can doesn't mean you should
but we're doing a demo right right
because I do that alright I'm going to
go ahead and apply this and let's see
how that plays out and so obviously here
this is not I mean if you want to
customize the Google base map you can
still do that using the the existing
approach of applying styles to the
Google basement but clearly this is
working with your data that's being
overlaid on top of that exactly that and
so now as you can see the labels that
come out from the name attribute are
being displayed on as labels on top of
the geometry and in fact a long made
geometry as well which is kind of nice
right right exactly that excellent so we
got new line styles and new labels and
this is kind of on that continuous path
we're trying to get from where we
started with a sort of the minimum
viable set of symbology and slowly
getting better and better and I think
our goal is basically to have some kind
of parity in terms of the beautiful map
with the consumer experience as well
just so it looks it all looks good okay
well I think the next item and the last
thing for maps engine we were covering
was the image referencing tool right and
so with the image referencing tool the
idea is pretty simple you're able to
upload a JPEG that has 0 geo referencing
I'm imagining in my mind a floor plan
let's say yeah where you need to place
on top of the base
right and so with the absence of geo
referencing this tool allows you to kind
of align it with the base map tiles and
so I'm going to do that right here with
one of the data sources that I have
existing right so this is the floor pan
jpg image that I upload it last night
and with the upload feature now there is
the setting that you can choose where
you can say I want to manually align
this a cryogenic data source and so
that's what I've done so when you choose
that what you have here in the data
details page is a link that allows you
to open up the alignment tool so I'm
going to go into that first things first
this alignment tools works on the bait
what's based on three anchors that are
attached to the image and you you can
feel free to move around these anchors
however you want it once you've chosen
the anchors the next step will be to
align them wherever you want on the map
mm-hmm right so I'm just going to do
that right here by changing the address
to and so instead of having to drag this
across the tiles you just type in a
dress and that image will be dragged to
wherever the address that you had chosen
and I'm just going to stretch this all
the way here to make a little more sense
of this image I should add that you can
you can repeat this process as always
you've done it you can go back and
realign it as you see definitely exactly
that rude boy and so
yeah i think that sort of the benefit of
this too is that um you know anyone can
I always think of emergency situations
as being where you need to act quickly
and it doesn't have to be perfect fit
where if you just had a floor plan from
someone you need to share it securely
you can upload it align it and then
share it through Maps engine right
exactly that like you know if you zoomed
it into the base map tiles you'd see
more like an empty outline so it makes
more sense if you had an existing floor
plan to kind of share that with your
viewers all right and at once the
processing is done you should be able to
view that in your drafts and basically
any way you can use a max engine layer
you're going to be able to add that as a
layer or an asset right right yeah
exactly that um okay so let's switch to
the places API now there's one thing we
wanted to call out which is a sort of it
seems like a small thing but actually a
pretty significant improvement in
royalty a result throw relevance I
should say right which is IP biasing on
locally right so what we have for the
autocomplete nozzle in enhancement that
does IP biasing by default and so let me
start with a query right here I'm just
going to dump it dump it into the
address bar and run it and so this query
uses autocomplete endpoint to look for
suggestions based on the text that I
enter wa Sh so it's going to give me
suggestions on Washington so if you look
at the result it starts at Washington DC
if I scroll a little towards the bottom
i see washington street san jose and
then washington street sunnyvale and
that's primarily because we're doing
this recording in the Mountain View
campus and these are the nearby
locations that have Washington in the
address and to be more specific your
machine that you're making the call from
has a has an IP address associated with
that location right exactly that right
so that happens by default now if you
wanted to switch that off you'd remember
if you've been using the places API
there is the additional optional
parameters that you can add location and
radius yeah so that also does some
biasing so to switch off this IP biasing
you would need to enter 0 comma 0 for
the lat/long for the location yeah and
radius as 20 million meters that covers
the whole globe so that is indirectly
saying that I don't want to do IP
biasing yeah so I mean obviously the the
thing is a lot of times that developers
or consumers of the API are adding those
parameters and customers might be
getting results that don't really make
sense based on where they're located
this is kind of the first first attempt
to be more relevant right in the hopes
that you would actually include those
two parameters to be more specific good
okay right so just a quick glance at the
results another five included the
location in radius parameter to specify
that I do not want to do any kind of IP
biasing the first result remains pretty
much the same but if I scroll down I get
Washington Pennsylvania Washington
Illinois which is basically just names
of locations not just treats that are
near to where i am basically IP perfect
all right well let's wrap it up with the
final thing which is a brand new app for
Android just the Google Maps engine
mobile app sort of tell us what that's
all about one of the things I'm really
excited about so with this app and let
me just bring you to where you can
download this app which is in Google
Play this app is available for Android
today and so with it what would this app
is really is the merging of the existing
coordinate app and a new app that
supports Maps engine on the mobile
device okay so what I'm saying is you
can display map engine maps I got this
app yeah you can display your jobs as a
coordinate worker that I've been
assigned to you okay so what this up
until now it was only the job
administrator yeah who was able to
display map engine maps over the
coordinate console but today the worker
provided he has been given access to
those maps will be able to display the
maps and also look at the jobs and some
screenshots very quickly so these this
is a list of the maps that have been
shared with you through Maps engine
console yeah and this is what the
coordinate side of things look like and
so let's say you are working on a job
that asks you to fix a broken pipe you
can see the network of pipes that are
being stored in self out of maps engine
I couldn't even better example you could
take the floor plan you just uploaded
reference it using the image referencing
tool and say the corner of this building
area what an amazing example right but I
think the interesting thing here so you
don't have to have Google Maps
coordinate have to have Google Maps
engine you can have one or the other you
can have neither you and the App Store
is functional still a Google baseman
right exactly and then depending upon
who you log in and you authenticate as
an authorized for you start to see more
options more data in one place rather
than having to switch between apps
exactly that it's just yeah so I tried
out last night with a random account and
I was able to access all the public maps
that weren't even in my maps engine
consoles so as she's a great way to
experiment with maps engine mobile right
there actually log in with your just
your consumer gmail account for example
you can check it out well actually
thanks very much and thank you do yes
really interests and see what we've done
in the past past 90 days and I will see
you next time on what's new and
enterprise maps